pacific rim job oh god
i must be the first one to come up with
that joke right there you go
the tone of the review has has just been
established
pacific rim you know when people see the
trailer for this here's a common
reaction
and then when i saw the movie here was
my reaction
[ __ ] me sideways so when you see the
trailer you're gonna be looking for some
crazy insane
effects and action and holy
[ __ ] does it deliver there's some insane
robots versus monster [ __ ] going on in
this movie the robots the yeagers
are so [ __ ] cool the physics behind
them
monsters the monsters look real you know
they're not so
scary but they're fun to watch and they
and they they look
great a lot of people comparing this as
transformers and [ __ ] i think this movie
out does transformers by far you know
because you got
humans inside of the machine so there's
actual
human effect going on you're not just
watching
special effects fight each other not
just the action all the effects over
around from the costume design the
production design
the visual effects just looks so [ __ ]
good
this is one of those rare movies where
yes it's a visual feast and that's the
main reason to watch it but it's an
actual visual feast that you'll go i
felt i got something out of this film
the visuals seem to have impacted me in
some way
especially on imax if you haven't seen
this on imax
then don't give me your opinion because
you don't know what you're talking about
yet
but if you have seen this on imax kudos
to you we could drift together
not tokyo drift jager drift the idea of
people drifting the
mind compatibility man it just makes you
go who would i drift with
if i were to drift i would probably
drift with jim caviezel
think about it the guy had to embody the
role of
jesus christ who better to have on your
team of the yeagers
than jesus christ himself you need these
jaegers to walk on water and the guy can
do it without a [ __ ] jager and the
directing by guillermo del toro and his
cinematographer another guy named
guillermo
it's dealt taco just absolutely
beautiful you know i love it because the
shots
are smooth and it's handheld at the
appropriate times you're not watching
some
crazy kinetic all over the place kind of
movie it's all
captured visually beautiful the
cinematography complements the effects
so well you really feel the scope of
everything like you really feel like
you're watching
giants on the screen the 3d absolutely
fantastic
i normally don't enjoy 3d but the 3d was
so [ __ ] good
guillermo del toro really knew how to do
this home you could tell this was very
personal for him like a lot of homages
you got the monsters from back then it's
just like it's like a 12 year old boy's
wet dream in a way
at least my wet dream when i was 12.
that's right when it might the first
time
i ejaculated it was to monsters and
robots but then there's some good
performances too idris
elba we are canceling the apocalypse and
you know what i want interstellar to
join the club you know why
because this will be the first black
dick that i will suck the best performer
in this movie he is a
total [ __ ] bad ass and you can tell
the guy works out so he probably also
has
a firm ass and there's other actors
rinko kikuchi
kuchi kichi
she probably got made fun of a lot for
that name in japan not my favorite
performer but my favorite character in
this movie i thought that she was
[ __ ]
excellent like she's really great to
watch she's she's good to look at
if she did asian porn i would totally
watch that charlie day
oh my god i'm freaking out all the
[ __ ] time charlie day is city i love
it's always sunny in philadelphia and
what's great about this this guy really
shows he can act in this movie so he
sent me philadelphia he's like the
stupidest one in the group and then in
this one he's one of the
smartest people that they have around
and he's totally believable he's
very funny he freaks out an awful lot
and a scene stealing performance in this
film
not really in it too much wrong [ __ ]
pearlman that's right
the scariest jew you'll ever meet i do
have a couple of issues with this film
though i feel it doesn't meet up to its
character potential i like a lot of the
performances but they set up all these
types of characters and you think you're
gonna get some awesome [ __ ] set
of unique characters but you really
don't like we've seen a lot of these
characters before
a lot of drama in it that i don't really
find to be that effective
there's another scientist in there who's
like he i thought he was a little too
cartoonish and the lead
actor he's fine but he you know he's
nothing special
he does a funny face when he gets mad
i'm not too upset about it because i
didn't come here to watch the characters
i came here
to watch [ __ ] crazy giants crazy ass
monsters
awesome effects and it completely
delivers on it and it actually has an
impact you can really feel the hits when
[ __ ] happens
let me get straight to the point here
all in all i gotta say pacific rim got
it right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my show why don't you go ahead scroll
that comment box below
and tell me what did you think of
pacific rim did you like it
and can you come up with a better joke
than pacific rim job and if you want to
go ahead and follow me on twitter you
click the link right here
and yes i will follow you back because
i want to hear how your thoughts [ __ ]
work
and if you want to see a more in-depth
review of pacific rim go ahead and check
out my show called reasons to see
that i do with my buddy jerry where
we're going to give you a breakdown of
reasons 2c
and maybe not to see pacific rim it's a
really good review it's it's a lot more
in-depth it's so
it's like a podcast and last but not
least if you want to get updated every
time one of my reviews is up
go ahead and click on the subscribe
button right here
that's right normally i have a penis
joke here
but i just want to say pacific rim job
one more time